-Ladies and gentlemen,
the President
of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Madam Speaker,
Madam Vice President,
members of Congress,
my fellow Americans,
tomorrow marks the first
100 days of my presidency,
and our vaccine rollout
has been a big success.
Over 200 million Americans
have gotten at least one dose,
and I tell you, modern medicine
sure has changed a lot
from back when I was a kid.
Used to be you'd go
to your doctor and say,
"Listen, Jack,
I got my knees all scraped up
trying to catch a bit earthworm,
use it to get the biggest catch
over at Addison Creek."
The CDC's updating
its guidelines
on wearing masks outdoors
for vaccinated Americans.
You'll no longer
have to wear a mask
when you take your best gal
on a date to the cabbage hop.
[ Coughs ] Excuse me.
[ Coughs ]
[ Sniffles ]
Excuse me.
[ Clears throat ]
Climate change is still
one of the biggest issues
this country is facing.
But if you want to do your part,
you can switch your gas oven
out for an electric oven.
Used to be we didn't have
the luxury of an electric oven.
We used to cook our food
by digging up the sidewalk rocks
on a hot day
and trying to fry eggs
using the heat
from those rocks.
Sometimes,
it wasn't completely solid.
Had that clear,
rubber egg on top.
Now that's the only way
I eat eggs.
One of my priorities
as president
is to repair the infrastructure
of this country.
Some people
might not like this plan.
It reminds me
of a standoff I had
with the scarecrow
on Old Man Sherwood's farm.
Scarecrow dressed
exactly like me --
patchy jacket, straw hair --
so I challenged him
to a scarecrow-off.
We'd both stand perfectly still
with our arms out,
try to outlast the other one.
[ Clears throat ]
Excuse me.
[ Coughs ]
Thank you, and God bless.
Actually, one more thing.
Actually reminds me
of a story I once heard
from my friend named Tim.
His nickname
was Duke's Suitcase.
-This has been the
President of the United States.